[Musique]
oui ma parole de total 6000 symbole du
puits cette semaine je vais répondre à
une question parce que la classe de
madame baume m'a envoyé plusieurs
questions tout aussi pertinentes les
unes que les autres mais une bien sûr au
réseau n'est plus à mon oreille en lien
aussi avec l'actualité
c'est à propos de la campagne des gilets
orange
c'est sûr que cette campagne a pris
beaucoup de place à l'avant parce que on
réagit quand même à la nouvelle en
conclusion on réagit encore à la
nouvelle des 215 enfants découverts dans
un charnier à kamloops un ancien site
des pensionnats et ça l'a fait ressortir
la campagne gilet orange qui
habituellement au lieu en septembre et
la classe de madame baumann me demander
non seulement tu un peu les origines de
la campagne vigiles orange mais aussi
est-ce qu'on peut combiner cette
campagne là avec aujourd'hui le mot de
la célébration des cultures autochtones
parce que le mois de juin
c'est me semble le mot où on célèbre les
communautés autochtones
alors pourquoi cette campagne se trouve
au mois de septembre et je vous dis à
tout de suite oui célébrer mettez-vous
gilles arrange commémorer vous mais je
vous explique pourquoi elle est au mois
de septembre
c'est que cette campagne a le vu le jour
en 2013
et les venues d'un et témoignages de
phyllis web stade qui est une ancienne
survivants des pensionnats
elle a été à l'âge de 6 ans dans les
pensionnats et une des expériences
qu'elle a partagé avec nous c'est à dire
le canada 1
ce qu'elle expliquait que pour sa
première journée à l'école sa grand mère
qui était très pauvre avait trouvé le
moyen de lui acheté une chemise orange
très brillante très très vive très
coloré elle adorait sa chemise
mais l'expérience que le vécu au
pensionnat la première ça a été quand
lui a arraché la chemise sur le dos et
qu'elle n'a jamais revu cette chemise
d'eux mêmes quand le demandeur à voir sa
chemise elle ne l'a jamais revu personne
de répondre à ces questions est elle
partagée que la couleur orange lui a
toujours rappelé que ses émotions son
opinion
voix ne compte pas donc l associer cette
couleur là à cause de l'expérience de sa
première journée au pensionnat a
justement je ne compte pas je n'ai pas
donné pas ma place donc à 13 en fait
laissé tomber enceinte
et comme sa mère et sa grand maman on
était elle même tout les deux ans
environ au pensionnat elle expliqué qu'
aucune d'entre elles ne savaient comment
être un parent car ça a été vraiment une
perte du lien familial et par les
histoires des pensionnats mais grâce à
sa tante elle a pu lever son fait c'est
avec le temps avec beaucoup de thérapie
et le passé à travers toutes ces
détachements de ses émotions de sa
dévalorisation qu'elle a vécu dans les
pensionnats
mais elle dit que encore aujourd'hui et
lui arrive malgré tout la thérapie
malgré le fait qu'elle comprend qu
extérieurs du passé n'était pas une
vraie réalité elle dit je trouve encore
le moyen des fois de me rappeler que je
ne compte pas et cette campagne de gilet
orange ii a été lancée pour rapplique
tous les enfants contes et la campagne a
pris beaucoup d'emplois parce que
c'était une campagne pour rappeler les
survivants des pensionnats l'enfance de
ces survivants le mais aussi ceux qui
sont jamais rentrés à la maison les
familles qui ont été laissées derrière
lé lien familial qui ont été brisées
dont le 30 septembre à chaque année on
met des gilets oranges pour se
commémorer et soutenir justement les
survivants des pensionnats
pourquoi on ne le faisait pas abouti au
mois de juin au mois de juin comme c'est
une mode célébrations mais c'est que le
mois de septembre avait été choisie est
parti avant la date du 30 septembre
parce que c'était la date à laquelle on
venait chercher les enfants et on les a
menés de force dans les pensionnats donc
c'est une date qui peut être difficile
pour beaucoup de survivants parce que
c'est la date où justement on craignait
le camion qui venait vous cherchez où
l'avion l'hydravion qui venait vous
chercher et ce à la salle a été le choix
de cette date la course mais avec la
découverte des 215 au cam nou est
beaucoup plus de découvrir à venir
le mois de juin de cette année ci va
avoir pris beaucoup de signification
pour commémorer justement les survivants
et ceux qui ne sont jamais rencontrés
mais aussi pour dire qu' il n'y a jamais
eu de justice pour les familles on n'a
jamais donné des fois même de réponse ou
même de signalement à une famille que
leur enfant était décédé
ça venait souvent des autres enfants des
personnels qui annoncent aux parents une
fois qu'ils revenaient pendant l'été et
ça pouvait prendre une ou deux années
avant que par an soit mis au courant de
la du décès de leur enfant donc cette
année il ya une campagne qui était mis
de l'avant pour dire qu en sol canadien
quand c'est long le jour du canada pour
enfants bonne journée de célébration du
canada mais une journée justement de
deuil national de reconnaître que le
canada a été bâti à travers la vie de
ces enfants là et que s'il ya un moment
de deux nécessaires pour déposer
justement un moment de deuil comme la
réaction extrêmement lent pour
reconnaître que de découvrir un charnier
de 215 enfants
c'est un moment extrême dans l'histoire
du canada et une réaction de rejet est
beaucoup plus rapide
la récente arrivée au ralenti donc la
journée du camp devrait annuler comme
une journée de deuil national cette
année et certaines communautés ont déjà
répondu la ville de victoria décidé
d'annuler la diffusion de ces événements
de célébration parce qu'il trouvait que
c'était de mauvais goût avec l'annoncé
de la découverte qu'il ya eu cette année
donc vous allez voir beaucoup de gérants
ressortir justement pour pouvoir vivre
de leur ramener cette mémoire de l'avant
et on a même entendu
certains journalistes ou chroniqueurs
qui appelait à des photos faites passer
par dessus
là on devrait passer à travers ça c'est
cette fois ci dans le passé mais le
problème c'est que ça ne s'est pas passé
dans le passé pour pour tout le monde
c'est aussi encore le présent les
survivants sont encore en vie les gens
qui ont vécu sont les parents qui sont
en deuil sont encore en vie pour
beaucoup quoi donc ce n'est pas le
penser c'est aussi le présent et de
demander de passer par-dessus ce qu'on
n'a même pas encore passé à travers
quand certaines des réalités qui ont été
mis de l'avant pendant justement la
commission vérité réconciliation qui a
eu lieu en 2015 à son derniers
événements ne sont même pas encore
atteint en 2021 la majorité de la
population
quand ces charniers là étaient déjà
annoncés et qu'on fait les découvertes
aujourd'hui on n'a pas passé à travers
donc on peut passer par dessus encore et
cette journée de deuil qui qu'ils
demandaient pour beaucoup vous allez
voir des gens porter des oranges plutôt
fait porter du rouge et du blanc pour
célébrer ils vont reconnaître justement
que c'est une journée importante de
reconnaître que le canada a été bâti à
travers les vies des communautés
donc j'espère que vous pourrez célébrer
le mois des communautés autochtones lé
mois d'écriture autochtone et de
comprendre que c'est pas arracher une
journée de célébration c'est justement
comment vont célébrer l'année prochaine
qu'on va avoir eu un deuil qui est
nécessaire pour pouvoir justement
avancer dans une réconciliation qui est
réel alors merci beaucoup beaucoup pour
la question j'espère que ça y répond
j'espère que vous allez vouloir porter
des gilets oranges ou des rubans orange
moi je porte un petit ruban orange quand
ma chemise débat disponible et j'espère
pour célébrer les survivants des
pensionnats ceux qui sont encore avec
nous aujourd'hui
mais leur dire quand on n'oubliera pas
l'histoire justement et qu'est ce qu'une
nouvelle manière de pouvoir en parler
pour passer à travers de poids guérir
tant que nation alors cette semaine